brand new intelligence has shown the
risk of a russian cyber attack on the
u.s has now become even more plausible
the steps las vegas businesses can take
today to step up their cyber safety
this past week a pressing warning from
our government about the increased cyber
risk from russia and dangerous new
malware that could take down our system
the magnitude of russia's cyber capacity
is fairly consequential russian hackers
just attempted to knock out power to
millions in ukraine now dire warnings
about a similar attack in the u.s
firewalls are such an important part in
keeping data traffic that we don't want
outside of our homes for american
businesses hearing this news again it is
important to highlight what can be done
to shore up a company's security really
having good what we call cyber hygiene
not reusing passwords using encryption
technology updating software restricting
administrative privileges and maybe most
importantly using multi-factor
authentication if you have that set up
then now at least there's an extra step
that the bad guy has to get through one
tactic cyber criminals are known to use
is a phishing email deleted the most
common thing that we're seeing with
businesses is what we call a business
email compromise which is where you have
you know it's also called a man in the
middle attack if you are unsure about
the legitimacy of email correspondence
hover over the sender to see who it's
actually from the account might say
microsoft team well then when you click
on microsoft team it's like dj five six
seven eight at aub tx 17. obviously
that's a scam and take steps to improve
password security if they compromise you
know your bank account and then you use
the same password on your email now they
pretty much own you russia is trying to
target american power plants electrical
companies banks and telecommunications
networks there has never been a better
time for companies in these and all
industries to step up their cyber
defense plan